giants general manager dave gettleman
spoke to the media today in advance of
the 2021 draft
here he is on the important subject
of how to properly scout college players
who
opted out of the 2020 season due to the
pandemic here's gentlemen
it's going to be interesting that some
of the opt-out kids
did a great job showed up at their pro
days and and just
you know were outstanding outstanding
and there were a few of the opt-out guys
that showed up and looking like me
you know so so it's it's uh that wasn't
real good on for them you know but
but that you know so it's you do it on a
case-by-case basis ryan you you look at
the film and
you know you come up with it and you
make a decision
dude on the right started last started
to smile and then he found out boss may
see this at some point i'm gonna
i'm gonna i'm gonna straighten up
quickly but uh hey
i i don't know that i'm gonna fault
somebody
who who dealt with
something that none of us ever thought
we'd have to deal with in our lifetimes
where we're shut off from the world
where we're staying home
where we're avoiding other people
there's only so much that you can do
at home and everyone reacted to this
differently and
if a guy has high-end talent and just
happens to be out of shape right now
well you get him into your building
you'll whip his ass into shape
and you're going to have a hell of a
football player so there are teams out
there they're going to benefit from this
if other teams say can't draft this guy
because he's built like dave gettleman
you get him into shape
and and you're gonna have a great player
so i i'm really torn on this
i really am because there's no rule book
out there
for how to deal with the pandemic it
affected so many different people
in so many different ways i'm not making
excuses
i'm just saying that if you start saying
well this guy's a great player and he
played great in 2019 but he
opted out and you know he he's not in
football shape right now and he's a
little bit spongy and a little bit soft
and we're gonna have to get him in the
weight room we're gonna have to well do
it just do it
he's gonna be part of the team and
you're you're going to
approach it that way to get him in
football shape i just i i think that
that if you get too caught up in that
miles you're going to potentially
pass on a guy that otherwise would have
helped your football team win games
well sure yeah and i think that part of
it too
is just that you have to make sure that
you're doing these things on a
case-by-case basis
because one guy's story for you know why
they may have opted out
in the covid year is probably different
from another guy's story it's probably
different than
from the other guy's story so i think
that a lot of these gm's have been
saying you know you look at this on a
case-by-case basis
why did they opt out what were they
doing when they then did opt out you
know how were they
training and i think if you see somebody
at a pro day that doesn't exactly
look like they were in the best football
shape well it stands to reason that they
shouldn't be
because they haven't played football
since the 2019 season so
i think as long as teams are really
trying to delve into figuring out
what exactly is up with the player you
know they're
they're they can do all these different
zoom interviews and you know whether
they're playing
uh rochambeau or whatever else they're
doing they can figure out
exactly what this guy looks like from
the inside you know what their what his
internal makeup is and i
i think when you're going after a player
in the first round especially you have
to figure
that out almost more than what it they
they appear to be on tape in college
because
you're paying this guy millions of
dollars to come in
and be a star for your football team so
if they want to if teams want to say if
dave gellerman wants to say man that guy
looked like me
he's off the board then you know that's
fine i guess but i think if that's the
only reason why you're doing it then
you're probably doing yourself and the
team
a disservice i had no idea that
rochambeau was the alternate name for
rock paper scissors until today how did
i live nearly 56 years
and not know that here's dave gettleman
talking about the possibility of trading
out of the 11th spot something
he's never done he's never traded down
in round one and the giants haven't
traded down in round one since 2006
when the steelers jumped up to get san
antonio homes here's gentlemen
we have i've tried in the past i i
honestly
honest i've tried to trade back
but it's going to be value i'm not
getting fleeced
i refuse to do it and if you know
somebody wants to make a bad trade back
god bless them and but you know we've
had opportunities i've tried
you know and there you have to
understand
the other piece of this dan is sometimes
you have a trade
and the guy that the team is trading up
for gets picked in front of you i've had
we've had that happen to us
we got a trade we got to trade and the
and the so-and-so selects
no trade dave good-bye hang the phone up
on me
so that happens too i mean it's really
it's it's like it's almost becoming
urban myth
the reality a lot of teams ready to
trade down not many
teams willing to trade up and one of the
realities next year's draft picks will
be more valuable than this year's
because next year you can properly scout
this year
you can't properly scout no combine no
private workouts
no visits to the facility hopefully next
year the full allotment of scouting
tools will be available
yeah you know what though man i mean
that i tried i'm telling you i've tried
and
that was that kills me every time i
watch it i've seen it a few times now
today and i just
every time man gentleman just you really
just get the feeling that
he almost doesn't like this reputation
that he's earned and he almost just
seems like he
wants to be able to trade down just to
make us all be quiet because
he keeps being told that he hates
trading down he hates trading down i
mean my goodness man
it's hilarious but i don't know if
they're really going to trade down from
11. they could get a
bunch of different premium players could
still be there for them
at the 11th overall pick so i mean you
know i know that there was that report
that they have had
internal conversations about trading
back in the first round and
maybe they'll end up doing that but i
just feel like there's so much talent
out there
that i don't know why necessarily you
would do that
if there is a player that you really
feel like can help you win i
mean if you're at 11 you're at 11. pick
the guy that you think can help you win
and if you can't if you don't have that
guy then yeah i guess trade back but
in this particular draft i feel like
there's going to be somebody there for
them to pick
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports